لأول مرة يمكن فتح رحلتك القادمة من
خلال تقنية التعرف على الوجه
بدءًا من فحص الحقيبة
مروراً بالأمن وصولاً إلى
البوابة.
الوقت الذي يتدفق فيه الناس إلى
المطارات ونأمل حقًا في تقليل
التوتر وزيادة السرعة التي
يمر بها الناس إلى دلتا المطار ،
أوضح لي رون جون جوسوامي كيف
يعمل النظام عند فحص الحقائب ، يقول إن ما
يستغرق عادةً دقيقتان و 30
ثانية هو الآن معطل  حتى 30 ثانية ،
يقول إن عملية التحقق من
هويتك عند نقطة تفتيش tsa قد
انخفضت الآن إلى ست ثوانٍ فقط ،
وأعتقد أن التوقيت لا يمكن أن يكون أكثر
مثالية من نواح كثيرة لأنك على
حق في عودة المزيد والمزيد من المسافرين المنتظمين
للسفر في  ستبدأ النسخة التجريبية في أكثر المراكز ازدحامًا في
دلتا في البداية لأولئك المشتركين في
برنامج المسافر الدائم في دلتا والذين لديهم أيضًا
جواز سفر tsa تحقق مسبقًا  تتم مقارنة صور التأشيرة الثانية في
قاعدة بيانات فيدرالية مع
صورتك الحية ، وتصر إدارة tsa على أن الملف قد تم
إتلافه فورًا مما يزيد
من مستوى الأمان من التهديدات الإلكترونية والقرصنة ،
لقد أخذنا بالتأكيد
اعتبارات الخصوصية في الاعتبار بالطريقة الكاملة التي
لا يرغب شخص ما في
المشاركة بها.  للاشتراك
والمشاركة ، لديهم حقًا هذا
الخيار إذا كانوا يريدون الحصول على
التجربة ، شكرًا لك ، مرحبًا بكم في
مدرسة أرنولد ،
تحاول الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية أيضًا
التعرف على الوجه في صالاتها الطرفية في dfw ،
لكن خبراء الصناعة يفكرون في استخدام
التكنولوجيا منذ لحظة وصولك
إلى  يمكن للمطار أن يخفض الوقت الذي تقضيه
في الانتظار إلى النصف إذا رأينا أن إدارة أمن النقل تحصل على
هذا النوع من الزيادة في
الإنتاجية.قد
تكون الخطوط الأمنية الطويلة بالمطار
شيئًا من الماضي
الذي تستخدم فيه الدلتا بالفعل بعض هذه
التكنولوجيا في مركزها في ديترويت
وتقول  سيتم طرح المزيد من المحاور على الإنترنت قريبًا ، ولكن
سيتم اختبار هذا حقًا هنا
في أتلانتا دلتا ويتوقع أن يخدم
حوالي اثنين وآه  ألف مليون شخص
خلال فترة سفر عيد الشكر ،
أكثر من 40 في المائة من جميع
ركابها ، شركة الطيران على نطاق واسع بيت مونتيان سي إن إن أتلانتا